I read that when you were nine that you
really wanted to get married wearing
fairy wings so how cool is it now that
you're an adult playing a fairy and what
was your favorite fancy dress costume
when you were growing up oh you know
what I never had fancy dress costumes
growing up um and I did want to get
married in fairy wings although I can't
remember why oh that's probably because
I didn't have any costumes growing up I
had a delayed adolescence a rest of
development there what is it so cool
about playing a fairy um I just think
it's such an iconic comping to the Tooth
Fairy it's not just any fairy it's you
know the most famous fairy in the world
although you know in researching the
role I've discovered that you know that
in France they believe a mice collect a
mouse collects the teeth and and it's
just interesting all the different
cultural differences in in teeth
collection around the
world